[Music]
are you shining just for easier for him
to get on board with Mia's dream than it
is with his up so I think for him he
believes that you know she needs to sort
of create her own opportunities it's not
waiting for people to give her
permission to do what she loves to do
there's no one like Emma and I think
she's she's one of a kind she's
different than you know any other
actress out there and so you can see you
know obviously that's that has obviously
people have embraced that in her life
but you could see how on the other side
of that coin how being different can
also can be can be hard and so you know
when you see Mia this character going
through this Los Angeles trying to find
a job you know you really feel for her
because you see how special she is and
how you know unique she is but you also
see that that's not necessarily what a
lot of these people are looking for
[Music]
I practiced some of those piano pieces
four hours a day for three months I mean
I should technically never want to hear
them again but every time I hear them
I'm still moved by them I mean it's
really really beautiful music and it
really you know I mean you know it's a
musical and so we are we live our die
own music